throw up throw up the leader's name the
leader's name is barbecue no way shut up
swear to God that's his name cause y'all
about to get smoked
[Music]
nice of you to uh bring your bodyguard
today Nick by the way thank you these
are my guys right here
dude
I'm a lover not a fighter you're the
killer
body parts yeah yeah look at these
things bro dude I'm not a [ __ ] I'm not a
fighter what are you doing I'm a [ __ ]
I'm just a guy that comes on the show
just be choking dudes out Nick's nervous
I know I see it I'm not nervous I'm not
nervous I'm an edge there's a difference
so Ryan tell us about the article all
right
why don't you tell us about your workout
plan I don't know if you this is this is
the guy for the workout plan Pilates
yeah you lost a gang of weight how much
shreddy dude 100 pounds literally 100.
it's probably like 65. yeah Flex Zoom
three Flex show them the tries now show
them the tries yeah you gotta make that
face
all right here's what's going on uh the
article about buff guys no but it's
about uh something that looks very
similar to this there's a trees
sorry I don't know could be trees yeah
um something big is going down in Haiti
right now
something really huge why Cliff's the
president he wanted to be I remember
that yeah yeah but that didn't happen
that probably might have spared this
fate from happening but in Haiti right
now there's a major thing going on with
gangs
and one of the major gangs has taken
over the fuel supply for the country no
way oh [ __ ] that's kind of smart so I
give him props too
but you're not good for the country but
I give him property can Bart dap them up
yeah but that's like the cartel right
yeah cartel just run everything like
cops don't [ __ ] with cartel government
that's true yeah same gig yeah so
there's a gang called the G9 family and
allies throw it up dude
oh gosh G9 dude don't do it now we're on
patreon dude throw up throw up the
leader's name the leader's name is
barbecue no way shut up swear to God
that's his name cause y'all about to get
smoked
is it barbecue in English or like
barbecue spelled out in perfect English
spelling okay so it's not like a Haitian
word no for barbecue then they just
trans unless it means something else
when you say it in Haiti but yeah well
I'm sure it does but barbecue is the
guy's name and uh so they've taken over
the fuel supply and because of doing
that it started a chain reaction of all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] which of course is
you know to be expected but uh hospitals
can't do certain things
Banks and grocery stores can't be open
um everybody's facing hunger and famine
there's like huge [ __ ] things going
on didn't they already have issues to
begin with yeah I'm gonna take my props
back though yeah yeah that's not [ __ ]
up I don't know you should know this
with Ryan
information
they may not have even recovered from
their last natural disaster which is you
know the was the earthquake and the
flood and all that no because White
Cliff allegedly embezzled a lot of the
funds right so and then he caused the
floods yeah what does ukulele yeah
he needed a he needed a Manhattan yeah
he needed that Manhattan office uh for
his charity yeah they you know the big
Return of the Fuji is going to be
delayed because of all this so the thing
that's crazy is that the gang leader
actually made an announcement saying
he's willing to negotiate with the
government and he will release a fuel
under certain conditions what are the
conditions isn't that just extortion
but it's for the people so it's okay
yeah he's gonna basically let the field
back out if they take certain key
members of their organization and put
them in political power whoa yeah that's
a mob [ __ ]
that's the real deal right there is Hash
is Haiti its own country or is it like
Puerto Rico where it's like a U.S town
oh it's its own country sometimes it's
cool to be a U.S territory
it's a good
because you're right you're right they
are requesting foreign aid to like help
them God damn yeah but no one's helping
them
I don't know if they're helping them
enough because nothing's changed I think
the time of that's over it's kind of
hard to help nobody nobody helps anymore
it's a little bit hard to do it and I
mean it whatever it takes to help them
here would be something like very covert
it wouldn't really be like a guns
blazing yeah everyone's coming in
because these are just these are gangs
it's not an you know they don't really
they got a lot of Expendables so uh
because of that because of this takeover
other areas are also now controlled by
other local gangs because there's very
little they can really do because
resources are so [ __ ] yeah so it's a
lot of [ __ ] going on he wants to start
this thing called the Council of sages
which would be like his appointment this
guy's gonna it's pretty good
that's kind of cool man it's kind of
cool dude his name is barbecue dude oh
man can we get wands or something what
is it the gang of sages what's called
Council of sages the cat is way better I
guess it didn't have a ring if you
forgot it in two seconds I just got too
hyped I just got I got too excited so um
one thing the UN has tried to do is they
I don't know don't laugh at this because
I just did it's [ __ ] up but the UN
said they are
um imposing an arms embargo freezing
their assets putting them on travel bans
oh great they're gonna be a travel ban I
mean not to sound too cynical but I
don't know that anyone's gonna help only
because there's no money in it yes I
mean that's that's being really
realistic yeah it's being really cynical
over there buddy I know you know I don't
want to go off on the ledge but uh
no there's no money in helping them to
know you're so negative Walter yeah
they're probably gonna be like hey let
them have their Council sages let
barbecue do whatever he wants and then
it's barbecue but it also does say that
it's highly unlikely the government's
going to Cave into any of their demands
really so pretty so they're gonna have
to kill those fools you describe your
military and just that's if they want to
but you know like with the travel ban
all that does is it like people oh we
can't travel to Haiti well you can't go
anywhere there's a travel ban
so it makes everything okay so then
there's gonna be like hey just let them
do whatever they want and then if
they're gonna kill each other let them
kill each other whatever
next that's I feel like that's what's
going on yeah they're just gonna wait it
out yeah I feel like there might also be
some kind of like die hard plot where
like if somebody tries to uh take back
the fuel supply then some some guy's
gonna hit a button and all the gas just
explodes I don't know it seems like
there's got to be a leverage point there
they're not just standing there and
going you can't have it they might be
that that might be it I think they're
too busy thinking about me dude they
call this guy barbecue he's not gonna
not like this [ __ ] up
that's his animal there's gonna be fire
somewhere yeah what is that the extended
lighter is that like but it's like 10
feet right
I think it needs to be a little bit
further and if that was the case of
course you're not gonna put that in the
news no of course not because they don't
want you to know exactly what the stakes
are but for sure they have you said
steaks
yeah dude so it's it's pretty hardcore
what's going on man and uh and by the
way that like announcement that he made
was like I think that was on their media
like he released it like the statement
of saying I will do this if if did he
like hijack a new station too or no I
don't know if they got all that he might
have just got a new station on me I
don't know man maybe I'm being a hater
but I feel like after that first
hurricane whatever 10 yeah I'm out man I
know poverty's a thing but I'm swimming
somewhere else why are you living there
that's kind of like New Orleans you guys
ever been to New Orleans yeah that's
rough I'm moving out of there
there's a genius in New Orleans this is
the genius The Genius of Louisiana after
Hurricane Katrina their left their
levees were three feet high yeah then
when Katrina happened it oh you know
obviously the whole city flooded they
had the money to rebuild they rebuilt it
like they should have rebuilt a five ten
feet no no they rebuilt it three feet
yeah no even if it's ten feet I'm moving
out like yeah yeah yeah yeah because
it's below 15. per day the entire city
dude they buried they actually bury
their dead six feet above ground they
don't bury their dead underground it's
because the whole city is below the sea
level yeah and so their levees only were
three feet high from you know big
hurricanes I didn't do anything but they
rebuilt it at three feet it's like when
I add one foot
budgets try yeah just try think about it
but no but it's because of the human
Spirit we rebuild we don't move we
rebuild not me no I moved yeah I moved
yeah Bart literally yeah yeah he moves a
lot almost exclusively because when they
say the New World Order like once that
big earthquake happens the new uh ocean
front is gonna be Denver oh yeah you
guys know about this so that means we
gone yeah we're all gone like what's a
big earthquake yeah you might need to
yeah you're supposed to go to like the
peak of Colorado for like the [ __ ]
water not to get to you type [ __ ] all
right what's the timeline on that one I
don't know like it keeps changing I
think it keeps changing but I thought
that'd be a great show like a great
sitcom like you buy a Suburban home in
Denver and you know you've got nothing
you know your backyard is your neighbor
and then that earthquake happens and all
of a sudden and boom you're not
oceanfront property I think it'd be
awesome sitcom yeah but you're also like
Oceanfront like an underwater Cemetery
you know it's like for now
what is this New Orleans ah it's the new
ocean yeah it's the new ocean and like I
think that'd be cool that'd be a cool TV
show like now all of a sudden you're
sitting on millions of dollars but it's
not realized millions of dollars so you
don't really know what to do you want to
input except everybody in production
died yeah everyone's gone except for
anybody who was on Superman the ride
because it doesn't go back down because
they're stuck that one time that one
time it doesn't work you're stuck and
they're like oh thank God this ride
[ __ ] sucks
and these are [ __ ] facing helpers you
can't even see everything that's going
on down below Life Is Life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign